my name is jeffrey i'm a program manager
here at microsoft and i work on all the
data science and ai tools within visual
studio code
and there's some my contact info if you
wanna wanna get get in touch
so um obviously i just wanna start with
a quick demo of what we're actually
building today and along the lines like
i mentioned we're gonna be showcasing
all the cool data science tools that we
have in vs code
so uh we're actually i've actually
created this website and it's already
hosted in azure web apps
and this is what our final product is
gonna be it's just the website that um
it takes in the image url um it passes
this image to my model that i've already
predefined it's also hosted in azure and
it will generate the peppery detector
and give me a prediction of what it is
so i can just go to search for images of
my favorite pet breed which is
shiva's because they're so cute um let's
just pick this image
i can right click copy image address go
back
to my website paste it in it gives me a
preview of what it is and if i click
submit
it actually passes this image to my
model and it gives me a prediction so
you can see here it accurately predicted
sheba's
so this is what we're essentially going
to be building today
so how do we actually classify how are
we going to classify dogs and cats and
more importantly pet breeds well it's
really easy for us as humans to detect
the difference between
like certain especially between dogs and
cats but with pet breeds
you can see between these two it's also
um it might be a lot harder for even
humans so to do this we're actually
going to be training
um a computer vision model to do the
same thing so as humans we've been
trained to essentially tell the
difference between these pet breeds and
dogs
but we're going to be doing the same
thing with our
computer vision model so to do this
we're going to be going
through our traditional machine learning
workflow so this is something that
almost all data scientists go through
so we're going to start with our data
exploration phase so this is includes
things such as getting our data set
up doing the data cleaning we're going
to move on to our training step which is
where we're going to actually
create our training script uh we're
going to be doing this entrepreneur
notebooks abs code
um defining some compute so obviously
you probably don't want to run this on
your local machine or it'll take forever
we're going to be running this on a more
powerful gpu system
and then finally we're going to actually
productionize our code and deploy it to
azure in the cloud like you just saw
i had that website hosted and this is
our final step
so the first step like i mentioned is
data exploration
so to do this we're going to be using
something called the oxford pet data set
so it's a data set from the university
of oxford it has around 37 different
categories of pep reads and around 200
images of
per class so this is something we're
going to be using in bs code
so we're going to go back into our demo
we're going to go into our favorite
editor and id
visual studio code so to actually get um
you can see here this the notebook i've
already created but to get
the data science features within vs code
you'll obviously first need to install
visual studio code which is completely
free and cross-platform so work on mac
windows and linux
and the more important thing is you need
to install the python extension because
that is where all of our data science
goodies are
held so to do this you just quickly
click on the extensions tab and then
search for the keyword python
and it should be the first one that pops
up and authored by microsoft and then
you can quickly install it
i've already installed it for the sake
of this demo but once you actually have
it installed you'll see this
start page up here and pop up and here
you can just do things like if you want
to create your own notebook you can do
it but i already have an existing
notebook which
i can click on this to create and uh
sorry to open up an existing notebook
and it opened up in what we call our
notebook editor
so this is a brand new feature that we
released near the end of last year
and you can see it's um it's your
traditional jupiter notebook ui type
view so you have your cells
you have your input outputs if you have
any output cells it'll show below
you can have markdown and everything and
what's really great about the notebook
editor vs code
is that it combines the flexibility of
jupiter notebooks as
a um as a data science or just python
editing tool in general so you can
because you can run cells on order and
everything but with the power and
vs code as editor id so one example of
this is you have
full and intellisense and autocomplete
support within vs
within your cells in vs code so if i
want to do for example import
pandas as gd and then i can type pd
dot and then it will actually you can
see a lot of these auto completions are
popping up as i'm writing it so if i
want to also do os
dot um it gives me the top suggestions
of what
um what it thinks i want to do with this
package os so if i want to
i don't know make a path or something i
can type that as well and then
it gives me these suggestions which is
really great because traditional jupiter
notebooks often doesn't support this
great so now we can um the first step
like i mentioned with the data
exploration is actually importing our
data set
into our local machine so to do this
i have this cell so the first style is
just some generic imports i needed to do
but the next part is actually importing
the data set onto my machine
so i have my data set url which is
pointing to that same oxford dataset
and i've written a bunch of helper
functions as you'll see um throughout
this presentation
um in my notebook just to clean up the
code a little bit so you have to worry
too much about the code but if you're
ever interested in learning
more specifically of how all the code
works and how these helper functions
or what these helper functions actually
do i'll be including a link at the end
of my demo or
at the end of this talk to the github
repo so you can actually look at the
code yourself in your own time
but in this code that's all it's going
to do is it's going to download this
data
set um and it's going to save it into my
local workspace
so you can see here if i go to my files
tab um if you can see i have this images
subfolder so i've already run the cell
just for the sake of time i've already
pre-downloaded it
and it's separated into its training and
validation step and you can see all the
different pet breeds are here
so once we actually have our data set
downloaded onto a machine
one thing we want to do as a traditional
data scientist you want to actually make
sure that that data is correct
so just do a sanity check and to do this
i've written this really
simple function um using matplotlib and
what the function does is it will just
plot random samples of each of the
categories of images
so you can see here i can just do a
quick sanity check to make sure that
these images look right there's no like
really weird images there's no images of
i don't know maybe like a snake or pig
so we can make sure that these images
are correct but another really great way
is uh we have a we also fully support
custom ipi widgets so you can see that
this plot
using matplotlib which is a really great
library
you can see it's really static there's
no real interaction with it you just
look at it
but with ipi widgets if we run this cell
ico widgets are essentially a more
interactive
plotting or interactive experience so
you can see here if i want to look at my
plots or my
training images more interactively i can
actually scroll between um
and look through the different um look
through my different cut screens so it's
kind of like a uh
a more customized interactive ui and we
fully support this within vs code as
well
great so now that we've actually
imported our data set and then quickly
look through our data set to make sure
that all the data is correct
now we can start transforming our data
into tensors
so um like i mentioned we're going to be
doing this type detector and to train it
we're going to be using something
we're going to be using a python
framework called pi torch which is a
really popular
deep learning framework but pytorch
doesn't actually understand
these image files it needs to actually
be converted into something called
tensors which you can just think about
as
a matrices of numbers and we need to
convert them to tensors before we can
um actually pass into the training uh
pass it to the model sorry
so to do this um usually you just want
to apply some transform so here i'm just
cropping them because all these images
can be different sizes so i'm going to
want to make everything uniform and
standard before it passes the model i'm
going to crop it
apply some transformations and then
convert it to a tensor so i can again i
can run the cell by just clicking this
run cell icon or i can actually run the
cell by uh we fully support jupiter
hotkeys as well so if i want to
use my shift enter i can just type shift
enter and it'll also run the cell as
well
um so with these transforms it's often
really easy to make a really quick
mistake or it's hard to tell
it's really easy to make a one-off error
because these are just numbers and
you're applying these transforms
so a really great way to check to see if
these transformers are actually
performing properly
is with the feature we uh recently added
called run by line
so you think you can think of run by
line as a simplified notebook debugging
experience
um so what this means is that um i'll
just show you with the example
there's this run by line icon here and
what run by line does is
it steps through your code line by line
and gives you a state
of it shows you a state of all your
variables at each line of code
so rather than having to write print
statements between all these so maybe
you have to write
print image.shape instead of having to
do that
on having a bunch of print statements
and just generally taking more time
you can actually run um this sorry you
can run run by line
and it will actually showcase um you can
see it's
stopping stopping at the first line of
code and it'll step through each of the
lines of code and tell you the state of
all your variables
and actually showcases the state in what
we call our variable explorer so
if you can see i open up the variable
explorer at the top of my notebook here
and i wanted to look at the variable
image because that's the one i'm most
interested in so if i look at image you
can see right now it's
just a jpeg image file because in the
previous cell i just
i just opened up a random sample image
just to test to see if my transforms are
working
so as you can see um if you pay
attention let me just uh make this
bigger because i zoomed in
um i zoomed in on
vs code just so everyone can see better
but you can see um image right now is
around 500 by 375 pixels
so if you remember the first step is i
crop it to 224 by 224
um so you can see as this is running um
yep so you can see now the size is 224
by 224 so you can see the
crop actually worked um and i can
continue to step
through my code and if there was an
error it would just stop and tell me
there's an error but so far there's no
errors which is great
um then i next transform into a tensor
so you can see
um the image afterwards it transforms
you can see now it's a tensor type
before it was an image type so
and now now i know that this tensor
transformation is actually working
and then finally at the end it just
finishes and it knows that um
because i got no errors um and
everything looks right so far that i can
now apply this
transformation to all my images so i
just wanted to test on one image before
i did it on everything
great so let me just close up my
variable explorer again and the next
line is where i'm actually
i've written this function previously to
just do the same transformation but
instead of just that one image do it on
all my images
in my uh in my data set
great so now we just did the data
exploration phase so um
like you saw we imported our data set we
did some data cleaning where we
quickly checked all our data within our
matplotlib just to see if everything
looked great and then we converted
everything into something that
the computer and more importantly pi
torch will understand when we do the
training step so now we're going to
actually head to the training phase
so again we're going to go back to vs
code for this
so um in the training phase we're
actually uh all we're doing is
we're applying something called transfer
learning and to do this we're just
taking a pre-trained um neural network
and so we're taking something called
resonant 18
but we're actually just setting up the
model um within vs code
this is all from pytorch as well and
we're going to actually train the model
so i've already written this training
function and again if you want to learn
more about how the training function
works um please check out the github
repo
and this presentation but um for the
sake of this demo
um i'm just trained it for one epoch and
you can think of epochs as iterations so
the more iterations you do um
generally the better accuracy you're
gonna get so i only did it for one just
to show proof of concept but you can see
um
after training it for one iteration
essentially uh
it this kind of took 40 minutes almost
to run which is
extremely slow because i'm running just
on my personal laptop and
i think we can do a lot faster than this
so to do this uh we're actually
we can actually leverage um something
called
azure vms so azure vms are actually
um we can leverage azure vms because
they have
gpu compute and this is where these deep
learning models actually thrive
so to do this i just need to actually
download this azure
vms extension so i can search azure
virtual machines
and you can see here um i already have
it installed but once you actually have
your azure virtual machine um this
extension installed you can quickly
go into your azure tab this azure tab
will now pop up you can go into virtual
machines
and then you can see i've created a
virtual machine already for euro python
and then what's also great is vs code
has
really great uh remote um remote ssh
support so you can actually connect
remote machines and then do everything
you're doing
live on the room the same thing that
you're doing your local machine on that
remote machine
so what we're actually going to do is
we're also going to install the remote
ssh extension
okay of the safe extension and then from
here we can actually connect to
you'll see this button up here and then
you can actually connect to your remote
machine
and i already have the setup but for the
sake of time just gonna quickly skip
over this but
um this will uh this will just pop up a
new vs code window
it will look the exact same thing as
this as you saw already but it's now
gonna be running on your remote machine
and then on that remote machine we've
gone i ran the same training uh
the same exact same code the exact same
file
but i've ran it and it's actually got
the same accuracy
might be some errors with my connection
but um i got the same accuracy
but with uh i ran for 10 iterations
sorry this is only one so it took
my local machine it took 40 minutes to
run one iteration but on that remote
azure machine it actually took
um around 15 minutes to run 10
iterations which is
insane about how much of a speed up i
got from
using the remote machine versus my local
machine
so now that we've actually trained our
model um we actually need to save our
model which is the final portion
so i just have this basic function which
saves the model and once we have the
model saved
we can start deploying it to the cloud
so now we're actually on we've completed
our data exploration we've completed our
training and now we're ready to
productionize the model
so to do this we have this really great
feature that we called that we just
released recently called gather
and you can see the button for gathered
right here and gather is essentially a
dependency analysis and code cleanup
tool
and what it does is it will just look
through all the code in your notebook
and look through all the cells and all
the code and only extract the relevant
code and lines of code only extract the
relevant cells and lines of code
that are required to generate the cell
so if i click on this button
it will just give me a new file called
the gather notebook and you can see it
only contains
the code that is required to generate my
model so you can see it only contained
the data set um
transforming the data and the training
and it left out all these plots because
it realizes these are just intermediate
steps that were not needed
i left out a bunch of my markdown cells
because that's not needed as well and it
left out a bunch of imports so only you
can see it only kept the key imports as
well
uh finally i just need to move
this sorry um so finally once you're
actually in this gathered notebook to
productionize your code instead of
having you usually want to convert that
python script
because you can't really do much with a
notebook to deploy um instead of
um having to copy and paste your code
over you can actually
have a we have a feature called export
where you can just quickly export as a
python script
and boom it's now a python file where
you can start refactoring your code and
change it into something that you can
basically refactor it and
get it ready for production to deploy to
the cloud
so speaking of the cloud we're going to
get to the deployment step now where um
here's the
outline which is just showing you how
we're going to use this so previously we
used vs code and azure virtual machines
to leverage the compute but now we're
going to actually make use of these
three azure functions called
um azure services sorry called azure
storage azure functions in azure web
apps
so we're going to be using azure storage
to actually store our model because we
want it to be
kind of like a micro service where we
don't have to update the entire web app
each time
we can just upload the model directly to
here and our api or whatever we'll read
from this um this microservice the next
step is we're going to be using azure
functions
we're going to next use azure functions
where
azure functions you can think about as
an api service and this is where we're
actually going to host our api endpoint
for the model so this is where the
our um this is where the website's
actually going to call it and finally
we're going to be using azure web apps
which is the front end so that's the
front end we saw at the beginning the
presentation of the demo where i hosted
the
um the website where i actually did the
prediction of the pet breed
and what's really great is because azure
is so tightly coupled with vs code i can
do everything
to deploy from the from within vs code i
don't need to go anywhere else
so again to do this i just need to
install the relevant azure extensions
and again these are all completely free
um these extensions so you can just uh
you can see i already have
them installed so i have azure app
service azure functions
azure storage and the first step like i
mentioned is i want to deploy my
model to the storage so if i just open
my storages tab i can see
um i have i want to create a container
to actually store my
model and i've already created a pet
detector but if you want to create your
own you can just right click and click
create
and to deploy it you just right click
and click upload block bob
and then from here you can quickly
scroll to where your model is so
i have my model folder right here and
it's a checkpoint.pht because that's
what tensorflow saves it as and i can
just quickly click it and then click
upload
but again for the sake of time you can
see if i've already previously uploaded
this once you click upload it will show
up here
so now that i have my model in storage
the next part is actually creating my
api endpoint
so to do this i will go into my
functions tab and um i'll create a new
function
and um you can see if i go into my
folders
my functions actually contained within
this
inference subfolder and you can see
there's kind of a lot of files here
might seem a little bit daunting
but what's great is with this azure
functions extension
you can just click this one button here
which creates a new project i can define
where i want it to be
in this case i created the inference one
and
here is where it automatically generates
all these files for me so i don't need
to do anything
and this predict py is the only thing
you need to create so when you actually
create the template it's kind of blank
but when you uh but once this is where
you're actually editing to
make your custom api so you can see here
this is where
i'm actually just getting the image url
it's passing it through the model that
i'm getting from azure storage
and then it's returning a response of
what that prediction actually is
and again once you have your azure
function created you can quickly just
deploy it by right-clicking
my azure function click deploy the
function app
and it'll just deploy to that function
app again i've already deployed it for
the sake of time
and again you don't have to worry too
much about the code i'm going to be
linking the code at the end of this
presentation if you want to take a
closer look on your own time as well
finally the last part is app service
where we're gonna be hosting our front
end
um so here is where we're gonna be
hosting um that
uh front end i just created a basic by
going to
i just create a basic html file um that
was what you saw earlier for
this and this basic html file all it
does is it just calls my api
that i've that you just saw previously
on my azure functions and then just
returns the result
and again super simple to deploy to this
i just go to my azure tab
i can right click create a new web app
but i already have one here called
jmu pi torch web app all i need to do is
just click right click deploy the web
app
and then just point it to that website
um so i have this website and then you
can see this folder all it
contains is that index html just one
file um click select and then it'll
deploy to the cloud
so those were how um and as you can see
all this was done within the context of
vs code
okay so i'm just going to quickly jump
through a quick summary um
just because we're running low on time
yep so we started off with their data
exploration we did this with the python
extension within visual studio code
we next went through our training so we
here we again we stayed within visual
studio code but we used azure virtual
machines for the compute
so we that's where we leveraged our gpu
compute to speed things up
and then finally to productionize our
code we used our different azure
services so we use um you can see azure
functions
as the api azure storage to store a
model and azure web apps to
um actually have hosts our front end and
the key portion is this is all done
within vs code so this is why vs code's
so great it has all your data science
tooling and needs and you didn't i
didn't have to leave vs code for
anything
so what's next um here's just the link
for the github repo if you're interested
as well
and as well if you want to try your vs
code notebooks um you can just go to
aka.net notebook so these are the only
two links you need to remember
if you want to remember this
presentation and
that was it thank you for the putting up
with the technical difficulties in the
beginning but thank you so much for your
time and listening